listen I'm big fans of uh both of you I
was going to make a joke to that but I'm
being sincere and I just want to say
thank you for everything you've done and
entertaining me for years
um for people that have actually never
seen anything you've done which is like
two people on the internet what is the
first thing you'd like them watching and
why hmm
yeah you people
um oh my gosh
no clue I had a I had a role as
essentially an extra in uh Hannah and
Her Sisters so they could so they could
watch that and see if they could spot me
just for you know it's kind of like a
where's Waldo
uh 19
80 I want to say 82 or 83. really wow
well I I similarly I I have uh an extra
e-roll in uh working girl with uh with
Harrison Ford and Sigourney Weaver and
Melanie Griffith um like in the Posse of
Melanie Griffith Staten Island friends
oh wow I jump out of a bathroom say
happy birthday some good work
these are
two good answers for you well honestly
I've heard a lot of answers before my
favorite though someone said they were
in Pulp Fiction and they're not oh um
she's like Pulp Fiction is my best work
or something like that yeah but anyway
she was kidding but she wasn't lying she
was kidding right yes I auditioned for
Pulp Fiction and it was no not Pulp
Fiction I auditioned for Reservoir Dogs
that was like a little late 80s did you
get it yeah I'm fantastic I'm gonna
watch that they did this head
replacement of Tim Roth on me it was
really pissed me off I didn't know I
went to the premiere and I was like oh
Tim Roth's head is on mine here's a Tim
Roth story wait I want to finish my
story oh I'm sorry I thought it was
ended I want to hear that you were
hoping
I uh so no this is quick so I I
auditioned for Quentin Tarantino for
Quentin and and and and and this is not
an imitation to Quentin but it he's a
high energy guy and he goes I I really
like what you do I just don't know if I
want you to do it in my movie it was the
best rejection I ever got in my life
yeah yeah
I'm Roth we were at
glows back in
back and then uh
sorry in the 90s
um
we were constantly uh getting losing at
the Golden Globes and um one particular
year they announced who's the winners
probably Frazier I can't really remember
and Tim Roth was at the table you know
at the Globes as people are drunk and so
uh all of a sudden Tim Roth stands up
and he goes you are robbed
you're a robbed like that and I
was looking around it was just fantastic
everything about this interview is a
plus everything I just I appreciate
everything you guys have said
um jumping into why I get to talk to you
uh I listen what is it like playing
someone who's delivering dialogue that
you know the audience is going to cringe
to as they're watching it because you
know what I mean like uh there's stuff
that both of your characters do and say
in the movie so is it fun are you sort
of can you talk about it I think it is
fun
um I think you can't you have to be
careful that you don't comment on it
that way because you're gonna you're
gonna ruin the fun if you're having fun
if you're if you're obviously having fun
or aware of why it's funny
um so you got to stay away from that
area of like meta or commenting on it
but I think
um for me it was it was really uh you
know to go back like
there's another thing that that through
shamling like he did this whole show
when he was young and Rickles came back
to see him and he asked him if he was
funny and rickel said did you feel funny
ah and I still take that as my thing
it's like oh interesting it's not even
about the take it's like my feeling
during the take like if I felt funny I'm
pretty sure it's going to be funny I
don't even know what I mean by funny but
we all know what we mean yeah you know
what I mean I do yeah yeah it's when you
you you feel like you got the bullseye
yeah yeah yeah what it's like for you
delivering lines that you're like you'd
never say yourself well I mean to to
David's point it's about intention
so if you can find a way to stay true to
uh the uh in the intention of the
character which in the case of the the
character that I played was an uh a
truly Earnest desire to embrace this
wonderful woman in front of her and
everything about her and to make sure
she knows that I'm on her side and it um
and and that's how I came at this you
know and um and I think as long as you
were in that lane
um and uh and had that sort of I felt
there was a kind of a an intensely
positive energy
um that it would it would it would be it
would have a satire that would work it
100 does I I needed I looked anyway yeah
100 does individual I'm about to run out
of time individual question for each of
you uh I am looking forward you just
wrote and directed Bucky Dent
yeah and now if you could tell people
what it's about and why you wanted to
tell this story and I wanted to ask you
what does it mean to you being part of
the MCU because uh you're now a big part
of it and are you surprised you got the
call and what has it been like
interacting with friends and family
being in the MCU I want to hear that you
go first
um well buggy dad has adapted
from my novel and um it's just a his
novel he's a novelist yeah which is very
cool thank you and and
um I just wanted to I've always wanted
to tell that story uh I wrote it
originally as a screenplay and then turn
it into a novel and then turned that
novel back into a screenplay originally
I wanted to play the Sun and then I aged
myself out of it I'm now I'm playing the
dad so there's a lot of stuff going on
um you know in terms of my personal like
just my history with the the story
itself and I couldn't be happier with
the way it turned out though I'm really
really excited about it
um to answer your question I would say
you know
um I'm delighted to be a part of the MCU
I'm really excited to see to shoot
Thunderbolts which we're going to do
this year it's going to be absolutely
wild
um I uh I'm particularly delighted about
it because it's really the only thing my
kids
are interested in that I've done that's
not true I'm I'm exaggerating but
um
they're interested in this of course but
and and but the point is is that for
years both of my boys have been saying
mom why don't you do a Marvel movie do a
Marvel movie do a Marvel movie and I'm
like gonna be for a Marvel movie and
then they did and I was like oh yeah now
my boys are going to be psyched what
would you do I'm sorry it's fine I was
I'm I I was in the wakanda forever film
that just came out and a few and
um Falcon and Winter Soldier thank you
and black widow jeez and but
Thunderbolts is going to be the the big
one coming up
um on that note I need to stop I'm just
going to say again it isn't a while I'm
not on the MCU now you're all over the
MCU can we put a good word yeah actually
you know what university can I yeah it's
a university and I've got a degree there
so I can write you a letter oh yeah I'm
gonna get you in okay so I'm not putting
it in public like this actually helps
yeah you think so yeah I do I think
you'd be great we'll trace it back to
this I'll take it on that note I need to
go thank you so much for your work
congrats on the movie